hi Pablo hi YouTube viewers my name's
Bruce Sewell and with things help I'm
the chief legal counsel and I'm also
responsible for corporate social
responsibility I think it's a great
question the difference I think though
between CEOs and doctors and lawyers is
that doctors and lawyers are regulated
by the state they have to pass a
licensing exam in order to be qualified
to practice and as a result the state
has sort of a heightened interest in
making sure that they have certain
levels of competence and that they
follow certain standards of behaviors
I'd be a bit uncomfortable about trying
to superimpose some sort of regulatory
structure on CEOs in general I think
because it's likely to have sort of an
inhibiting effect on the
entrepreneurship that we want to
encourage among CEOs but having said
that certainly CEOs are no less in need
of a code of responsibility or of a code
of ethics than are lawyers or doctors so
what I'd like to see is some sort of
cross-functional perhaps a comprehensive
attempt to define a code of conduct and
then make the adoption of that code and
the adherence to that code a matter of
voluntary participation but it should be
transparent so a CEO who signs up to
this that fact should be known to the
shareholders and to the board of
directors a CEO who chooses not to sign
up to this that fact should also be
known and could be taken into account
when the shareholders or when the
directors are considering that CEOs
performance and considering that CEO for
perhaps continuation employment that's
what I'd like to say